[Music]
the Waimakariri district council meeting
for June started with the
acknowledgement of two Queen's Birthday
Honours awarded to residents of our
district Mary Macintosh received the
Queen's service medal for her services
to the community including over 30 years
of volunteer work for the Anglican
parish of choirboy local orienteering
groups and various school boards in the
Khoikhoi area Gabrielle hariya was
appointed a member of the New Zealand
Order of Merit for her work in Pacific
and Marty mental health communications
work with Knight aho and volunteer work
and running film and communications
courses for young Maori post-earthquake
she has been instrumental in the
development of infrastructure and land
zone reform at Toa Hughie and is
currently acting chair of the mirai
council then considered a small parcel
of land and their own euro town centre
which was acquired for the Red Lion
Corner Road realignment with writing
work complete this land is no longer
needed however due to its size and
location that is unsuitable for
commercial development Council approved
the land being put into reserve which
suits the current landscaping and aligns
with the wishes of the rainy or Ashley
community board councillors also
approved for the business zones 1 & 2
public spaces policy to be made
available for public consultation this
policy focuses on making councils public
spaces safe and accessible for people to
enjoy it establishes regulations for
things such as outdoor dining areas
smoking outdoors and links bylaws and
district plan regulation for store
signage busking collecting for charity
and lighting the policy is expected to
be open for public feedback later this
month
the council also made progress on
planning for an extended curbside
collection service which is expected to
be introduced once the long-term plan is
adopted on June 19 council has the
option of owning the new bins all the
successful curbside collection
contractor owning the bins due to little
difference in overall cost and the
administrative and maintenance work
required and owning the bins ourselves
the council opted for the letter option
this will be similar to the current
arrangement in place for our yellow
recycling bins the council would
consider alternative tender birds which
include the council owning the bins the
next council meeting will be on Tuesday
19th of June with a long-term plan will
be formally adopted
[Music]